and now for a cute small child singing
my theme song say hey hey you can ask IJ
hey hey you I would I ever star in a
horror movie yes I would and hopefully I
would not die because every time I die
in a video my mother gets very
upset no pulse no purse John got a free
B in her money she can't be more than
[Music]
16 any last words
the color of my snuggy I actually had a
blue and a pink Snuggie but I just
recently took them to Goodwill because
I'm not going to lie Snuggies actually
are not that comfortable it's kind of
like snuggling up to a big piece of felt
that you would buy at the craft store
it's not so great OMG I'm so excited
about the new iPod Touch am I going to
get one probably not going to get one
because I kind of already have an iPhone
if you miss the update it's basically an
iPhone without calling capabilities it's
pretty sweet and no this this was not a
product placement for Apple thankk you
Josh no I am not from the Mansion if I
could be an astronaut what thing would I
bring with me to the Moon well obviously
I would bring my space suit and I would
probably bring some space food because
you can't go to space without bringing
space food or an astronaut
outfit do I like trampolining actually
no I don't I also have a strange fear of
trapezing but I recently overcame that
fear great just reach out there and grab
that
bar do it come on d y there you
go how's that not so bad at all is it
took a few tries but I did after all of
the tears I finally was able to
swing like and legs
up I don't know what happened there was
like so adrenaline and emotion that I
started
crying have I ever visited Alaska
actually I did a few years ago here's a
quick little Vlog of my Alaska visit
kind of did something bad I ate a
reindeer is this real reindeer yes like
Rudolph like that that kind of that kind
of reindeer boy I made the reindeer into
a sausage I did it I'm here to admit
that to you here today my mom is not
going to believe what I'm eating right
now the most terrifying thing I've ever
done actually I'm going to take it back
a few steps trapezing trapezing becoming
a trapezist trapist it's pretty
terrifying doing the KNE hang these days
come on well you need
all right at least you tried right now
I'm a really big Jason dero fan Jason
dero oh everybody's looking for love oh
ain't that the reason
you yeah that song it's it's pretty good
Britney what do I plan on doing as my
career what do I hate that
question maybe I will become a
professional tie dyeing
t-shirt artist I made this I made this
all by myself what do you guys think if
you want to watch the Vlog of me cat and
Lindsay tie dying check it out right
there this leads me to my question of
the video have you guys ever tie dyed
before Oh I think someone's here
someone's here at my door hold on you
should come here and be in my video
quick okay well we're matching that's I
know so uh guys um I I was just talking
about my career in life it was going to
be a professional tie dying artist wow
here's cat yes check it out so we
tie-dyed the other day we did it was
amazing like I really felt the creative
inspiration you guys should watch our
Vlog obviously we think the pink and
blue were the best colors it looks like
kind of like a starfish handprint on my
shirt but but you're like a professional
tie dye person I mean this is the third
time I did it and I felt like I got the
technique down I didn't want to tell
them that I thought I was going to be
pretty good at it I going to say
anything but people always they're like
oh you're good at tie dying cuz I didn't
want them to feel bad I know and was
pretty good she was pretty good you did
good too though that's thank you thank
you um pretty good okay sweet bye bye
guys it's cat cat riic thanks for
watching ask IJ I'll see you guys in the
next episode don't forget to check out
my last Vlog University episode and my
Vlog Channel other rustine check them
out and I'll see you guys
later